so when peter went up
Jerusalem the circumcised
criticized him saying why did you go to
unser
man and eat with them then Peter began
began to explain it to them step-by-step
saying I was in the city of Joppa
praying and in a trance I saw a vision
there was something like a large sheet
coming down from heaven being lowered by
its four corners and it came close to me
as I looked at it closely I saw
four-footed animals beasts of prey
reptiles and birds of the air I also
heard a voice saying to me get up Peter
kill and eat but I replied by no means
Lord for nothing profane or unclean has
ever entered my mouth but a second time
the voice answered from heaven what God
has made clean you must not call profane
this happened three times then
everything was pulled up again to heaven
at that very moment three men sent to me
from Caesarea arrived at the house where
we were the spirit told me to go with
them and not to make a distinction
between them and us these six brothers
also accompanied me and we entered the
man's house he told us how he had seen
the angel standing in his house and
saying send to Joppa and bring Simon who
is called Peter he will give you a
message by which you and your entire
household will be saved and as I began
to speak the Holy Spirit fell upon them
just as it had upon us at the beginning
and I remembered the word of the Lord
how he had said John baptized with water
but you will be baptized with the Holy
Spirit if then God gave them the same
gift that he gave us when we believed in
the Lord Jesus Christ who was I that I
could hinder God when they heard this
they were silenced and they praised God
saying then God has given even to the
Gentiles the repentance that leads to
life this is the word of God for the
people of God
good morning a a reading from revelation
then I saw a new heaven and a new earth
for the first heaven and the first earth
had passed away and the sea was no more
and I saw the holy city the New
Jerusalem coming down out of heaven from
God prepared as a bride adorned for her
husband and I heard a loud voice from
the throne saying see the home of God is
among mortals he will dwell with them as
their God they will be his people and
God Himself will be with them he will
wipe every tear from their eyes death
will be no more mourning and crying and
pain will be no more for the first
things have passed away and the one who
was seated on the throne said see I am
making all things new also he said write
this for these words are trustworthy and
true then he said to me it is done I am
the Alpha and the Omega the beginning
and the end to the thirsty i will give
water as a gift from the spring of the
water of life this is the word of God
for the people of God
please be seated his part has become
part of our tradition here at the
University church that on this last full
Sunday our last Sunday with full choir
that we invite graduating student
deacons to offer reflections and so
we'll have 3 reflections today we have a
wonderful group of seniors this year
you've heard them reading today and then
in between the reflections will sing
verses of for everyone born and so
Cantor will teach us this song I'll bet
you to sing the first verse back they
won't have our first reflection after
the first reflection will sing verse 2
etc etc so please welcome our speakers
I
you
to begin with I cannot believe I'm
standing over here giving the speech I
can still vividly remember watching
genet de Casta do this three years ago
so four years have flown but not at the
important part you all when I came here
almost four years ago I had no idea that
a place like you see why I existed to be
quite honest I stumbled upon this church
by accident my father in a parenting
move he doesn't remember but admits
sounds like something he'd say told me
before I came to college that if I
wanted my tuition bills paid I was
expected to attend church at least half
the time so being the goody two-shoes
daughter that I am my very first Sunday
in New Haven I said about looking for a
church and being a lazy human decided to
start with the one nearest to me
congratulations you beat out droid
chapel by like ten steps if things had
gone differently i might be both
Episcopalian and better rested right now
they have church in the evening so I
came that first Sunday and you were nice
and you had food and I just never
stopped coming here because aside from
being so amazingly convenient both
freshman year and now i live in l-dub
again let's question my leg choices
this place was just so amazing I found a
community that was warm and inviting the
focus our meeting in the center of their
beliefs rather than trying to push
people off of the edges his church was a
radical departure from the Southern
Baptist churches that I was used to
attending you see where I was quirky and
the people were very real and imperfect
and I liked that I felt very accepted
like I could be anyone here and I would
be treated just the same so at the end
of my freshman year he was invited to
become a deacon and I did because I
already really loved this place and I
wanted to give back and once again I was
so privileged to meet the accept this
eccentric awesome group of people I'm a
graduate students who weren't my TAS I
met people from schools and colleges and
majors that I would ordinarily never
have interacted with I learned that
differences even religious ones could
strengthen a community instead of
fracture it that there was a richness in
that and that was due to you all I join
LMG and I learned that the wine and
grape juice in the chalices are just
normal wine and grape juice from the
store until their parade over I learned
that you're supposed to walk down the
aisle from the front and not the back
when you're taking off right I learned
that ordinary people can write liturgy
and I got to see my own name in the
bulletin acknowledgments I learned that
no matter who you are or where you are
in your faith you can contribute in a
very formal way even something of value
to the life of the church so I guess
what I really want to say to this
community is thank you thank you for
teaching me thank you for being here
thank you for giving me for years of
love and support thank you for giving me
a
place where I could question and grow in
my faith I remember in my first year
here hearing Ian say that graduating
seniors shouldn't look for another you
see why that there was only one and so
while I'm confident that I probably
won't be able to find another community
like this I will take a bit of you with
me wherever I end up going this has been
one of the greatest formative influences
for me at Yale and I hope to remember
what I've learned here for the rest of
my life wherever that journey may lead
thank you
you
you
sidering Abby's talk I realized we have
some similar themes and ours there was
no no plagiarism went on here so it's a
pretty constant refrain for the seniors
here that you won't find a place like
you see why after you graduate that you
have to look for something new and be
thinking about what you really want in a
new church home so at first hearing this
really terrified me you see why has been
an incredible home and community for me
here in Yale I'm going to miss our
worship style participating in lmg and
Usher's and student deacons and being a
part of this deliberate process of
planning our very unique services and of
course I'm really going to miss the
people I've made a lot of incredible
friends here some really inspiring
friends and in general just have been
part of this incredible community and
most importantly you see why all of you
mainly this incredible assembly here has
pushed and brought in the edges of my
faith of what I understand God and Jesus
and Christianity to even be I will be
the first to admit that I came here with
a much narrower much more brittle idea
of my faith I came from a fairly
conservative background I'd only started
attending services a year or two before
I came here at an evangelical sort of
almost mega church I'm sure you can kind
of picture that sort of service you know
the if the idea of sort of like
interfaith cooperation came out that was
just sort of met with a no that would be
helping people that aren't like us the
idea of multiple pass to God was just
not even I've heard that at the pulpit
here but you know that was sort of not
even worth consideration I never met
someone who is openly gay in religious
and to be those two things at once seems
sort of impossible in contradictory so
you can imagine how hard Yale booba
would off all that it's actually
surprisingly easy to connect it with the
scriptures we had here today when I was
Ian sent them out before when I started
writing this and I was kind of surprised
to how much it resonates with you know
Peters vision of the net the
admonishment not to call anything impure
which God has made clean to rejoice and
sharing the Spirit of Christ with anyone
you come across no matter what you know
sort of earthly labels we slap on them
so all of you from your different walks
of life and with all of your big crazy
and often extremely untraditional ideas
have taught me that we can share equally
in God these people and these people in
this place haven't just taught me you've
taken care of me I still remember the
first service i attended here the first
Sunday of my freshman year like a be
kind of just I literally live next door
for an event room I a so I literally the
closest you could get and I remember it
sitting down in one of these pews I'm
trying to keep myself from crying as I
read through the bulletin through the
first time for the first of many many
times it was both familiar and
shockingly strange comforting and yet a
reminder of how far from home I was but
of course i eventually fell into my
place here and Patel has become a safe
haven for me and no matter what was
happening outside this place has lifted
my spirits and taken on my burdens for
four years now maybe that's why it's
good i'm moving on it's time for a new
experience time to learn new ways to
live faith that's certainly not to say
that services here are challenging
enough you know the motto is that we're
supposed to feel uncomfortable at least
once the service and we work hard to
reach that but still you can sort of you
can sort of adapt to that certain kind
of challenge I've gotten comfortable I
love it here and have given the choice
to pick up this group and take it with
me wherever I'm ending up I'd probably
agree in a heartbeat but fortunately
probably I'm not given that choice no
matter where I end up I'm going to have
to find a new community a new group of
people to be just as special to me as
all of you are and in part that's
terrifying if this is the place where I
really where I feel like I really came
into being as a Christian then how do i
define myself when I leave so I guess
now I have to go out there and figure
that answer out all of you wonderful
people here have given me these lessons
and these tools to help me
do this and I suppose now God will take
me someplace else lead me into this next
evolution is neces- and just as
importantly i'm so incredibly grateful
to all of you for the tremendous roles
you played in my four years here I hope
I've helped you even half as much as
you've helped me and I count it as one
of the greatest blessings I've been
given that I could come here and be a
part of the amazing things happening in
this congregation so thank you very much
for these fantastic four years and I
hope you have even more fantastic things
going on after I'm gone
hi everybody I just would like to begin
by thanking you all for the past four
years and what a supportive community
you have been I want to share with you
part of a poem i have written for class
day and the poem is called on prospect
street we will soon climb this hill for
the last time in May when the gardens of
Prospect Street weep weep petals to rail
against the season's end but I will
decide walk this road to grow past
little houses the river it's trees every
pattern line of topography then you and
I will spring into the lightness of
unmapped white in search of new york
troops i began writing this poem at a
time when I thought I was going to be in
palo alto in the fall so it's a little
strange because i will be climbing
prospect street for many years to come
for those who don't know i have decided
to accept Yale's offer for the ph.d
program in political science so I will
be here for a long time so I had two
problems that I wrestled with while
riding the last line I'm not leaving
gale so what your truce can I find a lot
of my friends have you no question my
life choice they said you're never going
to grow up you're going to be you know a
peter pan but also the line troubled me
because it sounds sacrilegious is in
God's capital T truth capital v Veritas
set in stone is my outlook in life to
relativist I try to find an answer in
the Bible and the way not to do it is to
just randomly open up to a
page doesn't work that way but luckily I
read today's Bible readings and I think
there is an answer in there in the New
Testament reading an axe God appeared to
Peter and told him to eat foods that the
Jews considered unclean that's a radical
commandment for a practicing Jew you
know Peters a guy who has held on to
this law of Moses that's hundreds and
hundreds of years old it's a cornerstone
with his religious and cultural identity
but then God reveals to him a new truth
that the body of Christ the church
should not be divided over issues of
circumcision or dietary restrictions
rather the church should be United since
God has made cling all believers
likewise in the Gospel of John Jesus
gives the disciples a new commandment he
tells them just as I have loved you you
should also love one another here Jesus
reveals to the disciples a new truth
maybe it's disturb my no truth to love
one another has been God's truth all
along god has made all of us in His
image we are all equals and should treat
each other with dignity but often we
forget and instead our society is filled
with hatred and disrespect and apathy
therefore we need the prophets and Jesus
to proclaim the truth of love to us
again and again so we may discover what
it means to love each other God is still
speaking to us that sounds like a GU CC
PR campaign but I think there's some
truth to it as Christians living the
faith today we wrestled with these
questions what does it mean to be the
body of Christ in our time and
lace and we asked ourselves what would
Jesus do in a world full of senseless
violence social economic inequality
environmental pollution homophobia
gender discrimination the list goes on
and on God speaks to the suffering of
the world and we should listen to him
and act upon his truth just as God is
speaking to us we are still speaking to
each other although some of us have
known each other for a long time when I
decided to come to Yale a friend asked
wine aren't you moving to New York or
San Francisco somewhere exciting what's
there for you in a small New England
city and I have been trying to answer
that question to myself so I decided
this weekend to watch thornton wilder's
our town on YouTube the Paul Newman
version there's one memorable line in
the play the dead protagonists Emily
exclaims Oh earth you are too wonderful
for anyone to realize you do any human
beings ever realize life while they live
it every every minute and the answer is
no most people go through their day to
day without recognizing the truce others
reveal to them but our lives do not have
to be dull grey meaningless cycles so
whether you are moving far away for new
adventures or staying in New Haven let
us realize the joy and newness of every
every minute we live